everybody excited for the carnival sure
I am
Pass
you're still going what time do I need
to be there set up noon spot
well you're helping out yeah why I want
to support mom man God you're just doing
it because Veronica's gonna be there and
who made Veronica hmm
mom what you're coming with us right no
I'm not come on it'll be fun
the old lady wants to be cranky and
alone you got to respect that I am NOT
cranky and I'm sick of everybody
thinking that they know what's best for
me hey did everybody see there's a sale
at Radio Shack on 9-volt batteries it's
a golden opportunity to stock up does he
really have to walk around with that
begging to get beat up
I'm more concerned about the biggest
bully involve the son you must be
because you're not able to hit the
target yeah expecting rain no in this
context it's a parasol from the French
Parra meaning defense from and soul
meaning son please marry no you don't
you got it
you might want to pray to the Lord for
better aim I'll get you started
lord help doors Cooper hit something
other than the buff a sari trash-talks
part of the job can I throw one sure
okay remember we want to talk to you
look where you're throwing and follow
through Oh dad bringing in the big guns
let's see what you've got this is a lot
of fun but why don't we let somebody
else take a shot
[Applause]
[Music]